y reforzar las fronteras exteriores de
la unión europea para evitar una entrada
masiva de refugiados afganos este es el
duro posicionamiento que han acordado
hoy los ministros de interior de la
unión europea que han priorizado sobre
todo apoyar financieramente a los países
vecinos de la región como pakistán e
irán para que sean estos los que acojan
a los refugiados afganos que a pesar de
todo aún ni siquiera han podido salir de
su país este duro posicionamiento es
también el que apoyan países como
austria dinamarca o república checa que
quieren evitar a toda costa una crisis
migratoria como la de 2015 y 2016
entonces llegaron más de un millón de
refugiados a la unión europea la mayoría
unida de la guerra de siria pero todo
ello provocó una grave descoordinación
desconfianza y también una profunda
crisis para la unión europea los países
europeos no se han negado tajantemente a
a refugiados afganos siempre que
sea de forma voluntaria y nunca
obligatoria la unión europea quiere
enviar así
mensajes sobre todo un mes antes de las
elecciones en alemania y de los comicios
en francia de la próxima primavera